Steve you're doing the cover story with
the 30 under 30 issue and we are
highlighting Daniel ak the guy who
started Spotify absolutely he's Swedish
right so you you actually went to
Stockholm hung out with him for a few
days there what was that like Daniels on
the road all the time they have they
have a big office in New York now in the
Google building but he was in Stockholm
he wanted me to see what Stockholm was
like so I went there right before
Thanksgiving met with him and they have
right in downtown central Stockholm and
it's huge not huge is a couple floors a
lot of engineers and it's interesting
that there's over 25 nationalities
represented in that one Swedish office
so he's kind of taken the best and
brightest of these young engineers and
entrepreneurs he was an entrepreneur
from a very young age yeah when he was
14 he started his first web company and
that was right in like 1997 1998 when
everyone thought they had to have web
site and in Sweden it would cost about
$50,000 to get a professional web site
done he started doing it for $5,000 and
all these kind of small and medium sized
businesses like theater companies and
welders and carpenters came to him so
not not like big fortune 500 companies
but like small kind of mom-and-pop
places and he was himself personally was
netting about $15,000 a month more than
his teachers more than his parents for
people that may not know because not
everybody knows in fact I didn't know
until recently what is Spotify Spotify
is a music system you download it on
your computer and you have free ad based
music so it's basically having an iTunes
library with every song in the world on
it and you don't have to pay don't to
pay advertisers pay right and then you
can it's a very social so you can create
playlists and you can share with your
friends and now they integrated with
Facebook so you can see what mike nor is
listening to or you can send your
friends hey this is awesome playlists
it's free on your computer and the idea
is you spend hours curating this awesome
site you have your library you have your
music you get hooked you know you get
the sample at first you get to discover
it first and then you want to take it
with you you want to either you want to
put it in the car you want to put it on
your jogging and stuff right so then for
$10 a month you can stream it to your
iPhone your Android your BlackBerry
anything like that
so he had all these businesses when he
was younger and he made a fair amount of
money right at one
we had a few million euros and he was a
young kid right and he decided in your
words that he sort of wanted to be this
Swedish playboy and but it wasn't who he
was and he kind of came to some
realization about himself he had all his
money relabel tip 423 it but it didn't
mean anything to him he was really
miserable so he moved to the woods near
his parents created Stockholm which is
the way he just played guitar all day
long right and tried to you know think
and meditate what he wanted to do and he
he comes from a family of musicians
right I something was Spotify it was
just a way to get make a buck but it's
musics in his blood he was given a
guitar when he was five years old he's a
natural at if he plays eight instruments
so with this little isolation he had in
the woods he realized what's really
important to him music and technology
and he found a way to quantify in a way
to put it together and that's what
Spotify ultimately was so this is a
passion for him it's not like I'm gonna
be super rich and be this like all-star
he said I love technology I love music
these two things motivate me and that
made him go and start Spotify and that
is sort of the ultimate forbs lesson
right he wants to provide like a basic
service for the web that's people have
to use it's like plumbing he wants to
build the railroad for music in his mind
Google has searched covered right
Facebook has identity covered right
Amazon is fighting to get that retail
kind of covered he wants to provide the
soundtrack of the web